The Conjuring, Constantine, and The
Exorcist. They all show a version of
casting out demons that'll make your
skin crawl. But is it really reality? Is
this what demonic possession looks like
in the real life? And is this how you
exercise a demon? Take it from a guy who
actually got possessed. Like, I mean,
real deal possessed. It's not what it
seems. I think when anybody has a
picture in their mind of exorcism or
deliverance, it's probably one image
that comes to everybody's mind.
>> Horror movies.
>> Yeah, that's what movies that that's
what Hollywood has done a great job at
putting out there. You need to cross
some Catholic priest.
>> Yeah.
>> This is what an exorcism is.
>> It's always a Catholic priest, too.
Never any other denomination. It's like
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's like nobody else believes in
that or that they or that they can do
that.
>> Yeah. And and you know, um it's it's a
it's a strange thing because it's like
the things that you actually probably
really need, meaning like, you know, to
confess all of your sins. And you know,
if you're dealing with casting a demon
out of somebody, I mean, there's a
there's a process there that I think is
is a biblical and smart way to deal with
it. And that's not what they show you in
the movies.
>> Yeah. That that's what we really want to
look at today. We want to compare what
our media, what Hollywood, what po the
popular world, celebrities are saying
versus what Jesus and the word of God
says. Um, I'm going to open with a a
clip.
Mr. Constantine,
>> in this film, I play a real man, Father
Gabriella Moore.
>> I am the chief exorcist of the Vatican.
My position was appointed by the Pope.
>> There is actually a real job in the
Vatican. The majority of cases do not
require an exorcism. 98% are recommended
by him to doctors and psychiatrists.
>> The other 2% I call it evil.
>> We open that clip and we're looking at
um a video from a movie. I think there
was just one released like long time
ago, 2005. Um
>> you're talking about Constantine.
>> Constantine.
>> They did a second one, I thought.
>> Did they not? I've seen like or is that
like I think they're like fanade
trailers and stuff like that. Okay. The
thing that was interesting is is
those movies which I'm showing here on
online. There was a movie called The
Exorcism of God. I don't I don't know
who played in that one. Um then
Constantine, when you look at the image
of Constantine in this movie poster,
look what he's got in his left hand.
It's also interesting that he's using
his left hand. I mean, maybe he's
left-handed, and that's fine. I'm not
saying that's a bad thing, but in the
occult world, the left hand side is
always considered the side of the devil.
>> And I always think it's interesting that
these two crosses are actually upside
down.
>> They're both upside down. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And and the one is a Bible. I
mean, a a cross in the form it's a gun
in the form of a cross.
>> Yeah.
>> And you're like, "Okay, wait a minute
now. Jesus came here and died on the
cross in order to buy our freedom."
>> Yeah. And like they're going to use the
cross as a weapon.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is not really what God is like
trying to make a statement with with no
the cross as a Christian im imagery.
>> But that's one of the things that we're
going to see here in this beginning
section is is that through Hollywood
through
the mindset that is being portrayed.
That's the idea that Satan wants us to
have of of freedom. And it's funny
because he does the same thing with the
devil. In Hollywood, you always see the
devil and he's just ugly, nasty. He's
got horns and he makes himself look
almost unbelievable. So that when he
comes to you in the form of a woman or a
man that looks nice and they're
>> or sophisticated or an angel of Yeah.
You you're totally thrown off guard.
You're like, "That can't be the devil. I
felt good when he was here."
>> Which is interesting because there was
one movie that kind of portrayed it that
way. Do you remember the one with
Brendan Frasier and uh Elizabeth Hurley?
>> Yeah. That was kind of bedazzled. Maybe.
>> Bedazzled. Yeah. So, the devil's like a
woman like an attractive woman.
>> Yeah.
>> And not as you know these other
portrayals.
>> Yes.
>> What What was the other one? Uh with
Alpuchccino and um
>> Oh yeah. The um Devil's Advocate.
>> Yeah. And who was the other guy? John
Kuzzac.
>> Well, Kiana Reeves and and
>> or was it Reeves?
>> Yeah. I think it was he was a lawyer and
you know the devil was this like you
know suave
>> lawyer
>> basically
>> there's there's been some scary movies
out there I remember years ago there was
a movie with Mickey Roor and he actually
spoke with the devil and the devil was
portrayed as uh I think it was Robert
Dairo that played the devil in that film
but anyway it's just interesting that
Hollywood is portraying freedom from the
devil, freed him from demons in a way
that makes it fantastic instead of real.
And that's exactly what the devil wants.
He does not want people getting free.
And he's certainly not going to tell you
how to do it.
>> Another thing before you get into this
too, um, that I think is worth
mentioning, um, I think because of all
of these Hollywood images and the way
that they've portrayed this is that when
somebody does want deliverance, this is
what their mind goes to and then
therefore they they like push back. I
mean, it it's been amazing. We've done a
couple programs on deliverance and on
casting out demons and um even in
listening to some of the comments and
things that people would push back on it
and it's like wait a minute like this is
very real. Why would you not want to
discuss like
>> getting delivering delivered from a
demonic oppression, you know?
>> Yeah. I think, you know, if you look at
the Bible and you look at the life of
Jesus,
it was ultimately God's word that set
people free. Amen. Amen. You know, and
and it wasn't anything else. It wasn't,
you know, something weird or But when
you look at Hollywood portrayals,
it's often portrayed as, you know, like
you said, you need this,
>> it's a ritual,
>> Catholic priest or a ritual or something
>> emlet. It's very rarely do you see God's
word actually involved.
>> That is a good point.
>> And so what are people going to think?
You know, they're not going to think,
well, I need to go to the Bible. Yeah.
>> Or I need the word of God um to be that
that sword.
>> That's right.
>> So that's And it's sad.
>> That is This is something um and you'll
have to forgive me. I don't remember the
the company that put it out. Uh it was
Netflix or Tuby. Was it Tuby? It was
Tuby.
>> Okay. Um that was the platform that this
was this film was released on. It was
called Celebrity Exorcism. You know, on
the left hand side you see like a scary
haunted house and there's these three
celebrities.
>> Um on the right hand side, different
movie poster for the same program.
>> Again, you see
witchcraft almost as being used in order
to drive out demons.
>> Yeah, that's a Ouija board.
>> It's a Ouija board. Ouija board, but not
the same thing that you would use on a
Ouija board. It's more like
>> it's a pentagram.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's like again when I saw
>> using the occult to get rid of the
occult.
>> Yeah. And the devil doesn't throw out
the devil,
>> right?
>> They may play a game, but it it doesn't
work that way.
>> Or he can control it.
>> Yeah.
>> Can Satan cast out Satan?
>> Yeah. I mean, honestly, if the devil's
playing um you know, both sides of that
fence, I mean, you could see why the the
the the Jews were like, you know, oh
yeah, you're just doing this through the
power of like whatever because that can
masquerade.
Um but yeah, it's like Jesus was not
using any of these tactics.
>> Amen. Amen. I want to show a clip from
this and then, you know, I want to get
get you guys to give me some input and
what you what you see in this clip.
This is how all scary movies start.
>> Are we ready?
>> Let's do it.
>> All right, team. We got this.
>> I'm afraid of the unexpected.
>> Is there anyone else here with us
tonight?
>> It can be kind of scary seeing something
that nobody else can see.
>> Are you guys doing that?
>> No.
>> Met, are you doing that?
>> Mm-m.
>> My name is Rachel and I am actually an
exorcist. I remove what people consider
demons.
>> I know that Hollywood, they have to make
it appealing. So, you look at how they
open that trailer and they've got a
haunted house and they got scary and the
scary music and and you know, and then
they're sitting down with a Ouija board
to communicate with spirits in order to
cast them out.
>> Can you imagine if they sat down with
the word of God and they're like, "We're
going to study the Bible."
Like, what would that do? I think it
would probably not be as watched.
>> Yeah, probably people click right off. I
mean, that is why they do that.
>> I'm guessing most people haven't ha
haven't haven't had an experience like
that. So, they're curious. They want to
know like
>> what's going to happen. You know, it's
the curiosity that drives it.
>> One of the things that um I had two
different people when the Lord set me
free, which was man, that was 2007.
Um, I had two different couples that
helped me to find freedom in Christ. Um,
one couple was from our, you know,
church, the church that I attend, you
know, our our faith. The other, uh,
couple was Pentecostal. Um,
both of them knew the Lord. So, I'm not
I'm not anti- any denomination, even
Catholic. Martin Luther was Roman
Catholic.
>> Praise God we had him because he started
the Reformation.
But both of these couples without
knowing one another and and probably a
year year and a half apart from each
other um both of them told me something
and this stuck in my mind.
Both couples told me that when we
started in this ministry for the Lord
20, 30 almost 40 years ago, sometimes
when we would go to battle with evil
spirits, we would have to call in other
people and we would have to have teams
that were praying in like eight hour
shifts or six hour shifts around the
clock sometimes for four or five days
straight in order to get the demons to
leave.
>> And they said there was all kinds of
manifestations. There was the stuff you
see in movies.
>> And both couples, again, a year and a
half apart from one another, you know,
in talking to me, telling me this,
>> they both said in the last 5 to 10
years, we found that's absolutely
unnecessary.
>> I was going to say it doesn't seem like
it should be that way because God's word
is more powerful than that.
>> Amen.
>> That's right.
>> The other thing that hit me was,
why do I need to ask demons how they got
there? Why do I need to ask evil spirits
who are liars? Their whole in even if
they tell something that's factually
correct, their purpose in in talking to
us is always to deceive.
>> And and any example that you have in the
Bible like um Jesus is not sitting there
engaging with them. He's actually
telling them to be quiet.
>> Yeah. If I need to ask somebody about a
person's case or if if we have the
spirit of the living God,
>> yeah,
>> we can go straight to the Lord Jesus
Christ, straight to our father in heaven
and through the Holy Spirit, we are
promised we will receive the answers
that we need, right?
>> I'm not going to ask, we don't have any
need to ask a demon anything. The only
thing that we ever need to have any
communication with an evil spirit is is
to command them in the name of Jesus
Christ to leave. That's right.
>> And the Bible says at the name of Jesus,
every knee shall bow and every tongue
confess. Not just at the end of the
world, they have to now.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> They have to.
>> And I'm going to be careful. The lady
that we just saw, uh, her name was
Rachel Stavis or Stavis. Um, that said
she was an exorcist. Um, I don't have
all the information. I have looked up
some stuff. Keith has looked up some
stuff on her. Um, I want to be careful
because we don't want to be critical of
people. She may have the best intentions
in the world.
>> Um, the thing that does trouble me
though is is like Keith said,
>> the reliance is not on the word of God.
It's not on the promises of God. The
reliance is on other things. She's got a
book that um she's released called
Sister of Darkness.
>> I think you just need to like pause
right there for a second.
Are you not a children of the light?
>> Amen.
>> Should you not walk as a child of the
light?
>> The Bible says so. We are not of
darkness. We are of the light.
>> So, so if you are someone of the
darkness, that just kind of tells me
like probably the method in which you're
going to do this.
>> You look at the subtitle of the book, it
says the Chronicles of a Modern
Exorcist. So, this is her story. When
you really talk to um anyone who's ever
actually
been confronted with c calling a demon
out of somebody, it's a very fearful
experience. I mean, all of them say like
this is not something you want to
experience. This is not something that
you're excited to get involved in or
anything like this. It's a very scary
experience. And and the first thing that
you need to do is is is is really ask
for forgiveness and make sure that all
of the sins that you have in your life
are covered. Otherwise, be prepared for
that to come out on the table
immediately.
>> Yeah.
>> And they never portray that
>> here. There's no method of um make sure
that you are, you know,
>> clean and right with God. And
>> the book that she's just wrote doesn't
say sister of light. It says sister of
darkness.
>> Um
>> anyway, so we're going to go past that.
But it's just it's interesting that
that's the one that they chose. She also
had a lot of involvement with other
movie making and and video games and
other books. I remember there was one
story in the book of Acts where there
were these Jewish quote exorcists
>> and they went to this man that had this
this demon or multiple demons in him.
>> Yeah. Acts 19.
>> Okay. Thank you, Keith.
>> And they said, "In the name of Jesus
whom Paul preaches, we're commanding you
to leave." And the demon looked at them
and said, "We know who Paul is and we
know who Jesus is, but who are you?" And
then the demons attacked them.
>> Yeah. Is that where they beat him up and
send him out and they get
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's like you've got this is you've
got to have a living relationship with
Jesus. You've got to be surrendered to
him.
>> Yeah. It wasn't I think that story is
important because it teaches that it's
not saying magic words. Amen. To make
that happen, right?
>> Amen.
>> They're not using a Ouija board.
>> No.
>> And it's not a ritual. It's not Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's not a ritual. According to
your faith, be it unto you. Through the
entire gospels, every one of the
gospels, every miracle that Jesus did,
this was the key.
>> Yeah.
>> You have to believe.
>> Yeah. I always wonder if I was in the
the DNA of of Jesus and I was confronted
with this, you know, if I had leprosy.
>> I know.
>> I mean, that's a that's that's a hard
thought to me. Like, honestly, coming
coming I'll just be honest.
Do I have the faith to see somebody
resurrected from the dead?
>> We're at the time of the earth's
history. We need
>> I read the words. I read the words. I
see Jesus says, you know, what you will
do is greater things than what I've
done. Um I I I see them. But I'm just
asking the the question and for the
viewers out there as well. Do you have
that kind of faith?
>> And if you don't, we need to ask him for
it.
>> Amen. Yeah. helped by unbelief.
>> I can I can remember one time a number
of years ago that
uh you know, everybody has good days and
bad days. I mean, us guys that work in
ministry, we're no different than
anybody else. Pastors are no different
than the rest of us.
>> It's true.
>> And I remember I woke up one morning and
it was just there was clouds
spiritually. There was clouds. It was
like I was trying to talk to God. I felt
like my prayers weren't going any higher
than the ceiling and I was just not
doing well. And that afternoon, I got an
email from a lady and she was like, you
know, Brother Wilson, can you call me?
And I I'd never talked to her before.
And I called and I said, you know, what
can we do for you? And she said, our
little girl who we adopted years ago,
>> she's got a demon and I need help. And
you know what went through my mind?
>> Yeah.
>> No, I don't want to do this. I don't
have any faith today. I'm struggling in
this darkness. And and I was like I said
>> and then the thought came to my head
when I'm having a down day usually my
wife is having an upday and if I'm
having an upday she's you know I have up
days when she has down days and I
thought okay that's what I'll do. I'll
tell the lady to call back when my wife
is home because that way I can be
involved but I'll be in the background.
I'll let my wife
>> because I know her faith today is
probably going to be a lot better than
what mine is.
>> I'll tell you from a distance how to do
it. Okay. Next. Do this.
>> No. I mean it there was no ritual. Yeah,
>> but I was I was afraid because I told
the Lord, I said I said, "Ma'am," I
said, "If you'll call back tonight at
8:00, my wife and I will pray because
it's always good to have two." That's
how Jesus sent the disciples out.
>> Amen.
>> Well, from that point for the rest of
the day, I was like terrified because I
was like, "God, I don't have any faith
today. I'm struggling. I'm I'm wanting
to hear your voice and I can't hear it.
And this woman obviously needs help and
I can't say no, but I can't do
anything." And I kept watching the clock
and I kept trying to work and watching
the clock and you know I'm thinking my
wife will be home by 5. She you know she
was a school teacher then 6:00 came. My
wife's not home 6:30 7 7:30 and I'm like
oh please dear God don't let this lady
call and
the clock kept going and and finally
8:00 on the dot the phone rings and I
was just like and I I I was helpless. I
was helpless. Even though I'm in
ministry, I was helpless. And that's
exactly what God wanted. And I was like,
so I got on the phone and she told me,
she said, "Our daughter's 17. My husband
and I went through a divorce a couple of
years ago. There's been all this
rebellion since then." They adopted her,
I think, when she was six or eight
months old. Um, the police had just
brought her home a few days before
because she had ran away cuz she was
wanting to see some boy. And the mom
said in the last couple of days she's
not able to talk anymore. She tries to
talk and nothing will come out. So she's
having to write on a piece of paper
whenever she wants to talk to me. And
she said, "Mr. Wilson," she said, "the
is messed up is when she's writing notes
to me, it's not her handwriting." She
said, "It's ugly. It's like she's
>> like ugly." M
>> and you know and I was getting a picture
and you know in my mind it's like I'm
going God I don't want to do this
tonight. I can't do this. I don't even
know what to do.
>> But you don't do it.
>> Amen. And you know what was neat? You
know what Jesus did and what our father
in heaven did? He told me just very
silently in my head. He said, "Eric,
read to her the promises that I love
her."
>> And you know, and I'm like, "Okay,
that's kind of weak. I mean, like I want
to, you know, I want something big."
>> Yeah. give the recipe to make it happen.
>> But I I found out why afterward. Because
she was adopted, there was a spirit of
rejection that had come into her that
was stopping her from believing that God
loved her and stopping her from
believing her mom and dad loved her
because her dad left.
>> So I just started I didn't have any
verses. I didn't have a list. I just
knew
>> you love her. John 3:16, God so loved
the world. So I started with that. Do
you know that after about 25 or 30
minutes she um and I actually I asked
her mom I said can you hold the cell
phone up to her ear and and she gave me
permission to read these to her after
about 25 or 30 minutes um she motioned
for her mom to give her the pad of paper
and she wrote on there in this ugly
handwriting please tell him not to stop
reading they hate what he's doing.
>> Wow.
>> And it was like
>> boom the cloud disappeared. It was like
all of a sudden I had faith again
because I was like
>> it's not Eric Wilson doing anything.
It's Jesus and God that are doing it.
>> Which is really interesting when you
tell that story because I'm sitting here
listening thinking you had more faith in
your wife.
>> I know
>> at that moment.
>> Good point.
>> You know, like it was all dependent on
her being there.
>> Yeah.
>> And God made sure she couldn't get
there.
>> It's not dependent on her being there.
>> It's dependent on God's word.
>> Amen. I I I think, you know, God knows
like what you need to see.
>> He's working on everybody's everybody at
the same time. You know what I mean?
>> And and and like um I think that that
you know, Jesus standing right in front
of Pilate. It's like all three of the
Godhead are engaged in working on Pilate
right there, right? The Holy Spirit's
working on his wife. Uh he's got Jesus
like right in front of him. He's like,
"King, who's the king?" You know, it's
like I only know one king. His name is
Caesar, right? And and and honestly like
like he doesn't realize like like he
needed to see that.
>> Yeah.
>> Like like like the way that that was
playing out, the fact that Jesus was not
saying anything, all of that that was to
to reach
>> Pilot's heart as well.
>> Amen.
>> And so the fact that you felt un like
like confident or whatever. I mean,
you're feeling helpless is like God's
like now Eric can help me. And you know,
and that's what that's what Moses did.
Moses was like, I can't I can't even
speak. And God says, you're ready to go.
>> You're the guy.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's what we have to do is we have
to we have to always remember it's it's
it's
>> it's God in Christ in us that's doing
it. So, I have to keep that door open
between me and and my savior.
>> Now, think about the guys that you just
mentioned in Acts, right? Overconfident.
>> What happened? They got blasted out and
sent out naked. I mean, like that's what
the overconfidence when it comes into
God's work does to the work.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I And I'm wondering like is it
overconfidence or is it just
>> I think they wanted to do
>> they wanted to perform the act.
>> Yeah. They want the power.
>> They didn't have faith in Jesus,
>> right? Because there's, you know, I was
just looking at this. There was in Mark
9:38 and39 it says now John answered him
saying teacher we saw someone who does
not follow us casting out demons in your
name
>> and we forbade him because he does not
follow us. Jesus says do not forbid him
for no one who works a miracle in my
name can soon afterwards speak evil of
me.
>> They
>> so there's a difference in in scripture
between those two groups of people. Like
what's going on? like one it works and
one doesn't. And so it's it's why are
you performing? Why are you doing this?
>> Right.
>> What's the purpose? And and do you know
Jesus?
>> Yeah. Because the Jewish exorcist, it
was a ritual. They did not believe in
Jesus. Where the other man, even though
he wasn't following the disciples, he
had absolute faith in Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah. Simon wanting the Holy Spirit to
to do what the Holy Spirit Yeah. is
doing and that's empowering people with
gifts.
>> Yeah.
>> Let me show a couple of other verses
here that that bring out what Keith
brought up. Matthew chapter nine it says
and when Jesus departed then two blind
men followed him crying and saying thou
son of David. That means king.
>> Yeah. You know
>> David was promised you're going to have
a son and that the throne will never
leave him. And in the Jewish mindset or
even saying this to a Jew, you know what
that means?
>> Yeah. He said, they said, "Thou son of
David, have mercy on us." And when Jesus
was coming to the house, the blind men
came to him. So obviously Jesus walked
by them because he wanted to see, "Are
you going to press your case? Are you
going to keep coming to me even though
it looks like I'm walking away?"
The blind man came to Jesus and said
unto them, And Jesus said unto them,
"Believe ye that I am able to do this."
And they said unto him, "Yay, Lord."
Then touched he their eyes, saying,
"According to your faith, be it unto
you." They were blind, and he healed
them. Matthew chapter 8, when Jesus was
entered into Capernaum, there came unto
him a centurion. And I love this story.
And this centurion who was a probably a
Roman um I'm assuming he's Roman
centurion but he beseeched Jesus saying
Lord when you say that word Lord in
Hebrew it's Adoni. It means sovereign
sovereign king.
>> Is it like a respect for like you know
like when you would address like someone
that's anointed.
>> Yeah. He said Lord my servant lith at
home sick of the Pauly and grievously
tormented. And Jesus saith unto him, I
will come and heal him. And the
centurion answered and said,"Lord, I am
not worthy that thou shouldest even come
under my roof, but speak the word only,"
which is what you were saying, Keith,
and my servant shall be healed. For I am
a man under authority, having soldiers
under me. And I say to this man, "Go,"
and he goes, and to another man, "Come."
And he cometh. And to my servant, I say,
"Do this," and he doeth it. M
>> when Jesus heard him say this, he
marveled and said unto them that
followed, verily I say unto you, that
word verily is of a truth. Means it
cannot fail.
>> Truly. It's like saying truly.
>> Yeah.
>> Truly. I'm I'm going to tell you the
truth right here.
>> Verily I say unto you, I have not found
so great faith not in Israel. He was
saying in the church. This is somebody
that's not even a churchgoer. He said,
I've not found this kind of faith in all
of the church. Yeah.
>> And Jesus said unto the centurion, "Go
thy way, and as thou hast believed," so
what's that phrase?
>> Be it.
>> Be it. It doesn't mean there's a
process. It doesn't mean it's 12 months
of probation. It doesn't mean there's a
rehabilitation process. It's the same
word that he spoke in Genesis chapter 1.
Let there be light. And there was. He
said, "So be it unto you." And his
servant was healed the selfsame hour.
That's that's powerful.
Matthew 8:16 says, um, "And when evening
was come, they brought unto Jesus many
that were possessed with devils, and he
cast out the spirits with his word, and
healed all that were sick, so that it
might be fulfilled which was spoken by
Isaiah the prophet, saying, Himself took
our infirmities and bear our
sicknesses." Now, this is something
that's interesting. Demons only, and
when I say demons, we're talking about
fallen angels. There's there's not a
difference between demons and fallen
angels. They're fallen angels. Satan was
cast out of heaven. He took onethird of
the angelic host with him.
>> Mhm.
>> Now, there's different levels. There's
different They have different
operations. They're not cookie cutters.
The angels are not all identical. They
have different gifts. They have
different abilities.
But when Jesus cast these spirits out,
he did it with his word. What gave the
spirits the right to be in the people
was sin. They had committed sin that
opened the door for those spirits to
come in. Well, Jesus said he took our
infirmities and bear our sicknesses. He
bore our sins. It says in 1 Peter or
second Peter 1 Peter 2:24 or 2 Peter
2:24, he bore our sins in his own body
on that tree. So he took away the sins
of the world in order so that he could
set us free. Because if if Jesus came to
somebody or a disciple came to somebody
and said, you know, I'm going to cast
this demon out and the demon says, I'm
not going anywhere. This guy's not
willing to give up his porn. This guy's
not willing to give up his appetite.
this guy's not willing to give up his
cigarettes or his romance novels or
whatever. The de the devils will say,
"I'm not going because they gave me the
right to be here and they haven't
they're not willing to give up the sin
that gives me the right."
>> So that's the first clue of how we get
free,
>> right?
>> Luke 4 says something. It says, "The
people were astonished at his doctrine,
at his teaching, for his word was with
power." Um John 6:63 says, "The words I
speak unto you, they are spirit and they
are life. They are it's not just words
on a page like a newspaper." The spirit
of the living God is inside those words.
And as you're reading those words out
loud and reading them, the spirit of God
is putting those promises inside of us.
And they were all amazed and they spake
among themselves saying, "What a word is
this?" For with authority and power,
make a note of that. With authority and
power he commandeth the unclean spirits,
and they come out, they obey. Jesus
said, "It is the spirit that quickens or
gives life. The flesh profitth nothing.
The words that I speak unto you, they
are spirit and they are life." Now, this
is where it gets neat. Jesus, when he
was speaking, he cast demons out. He
healed the sick by the power of his
word. The people said his word was with
authority and power. Look what he says
here in Matthew chapter 10 and Luke
chapter 9. And when Jesus had called
unto him his 12 disciples, he gave them
power and authority over how many
devils?
>> All. all
all devils. My deliverance was not like
a a one one day event and boom,
everything was gone because there was
things I didn't even realize that were
in my life that were wrong. And so it
was like God would he would reveal
things to me and I would wrestle with
God over that issue, whatever it was. It
was bitterness over, you know, some
things that happened when I was a little
boy or it was, you know, whatever. But
God would reveal it to me and then when
I would surrender it, he would set me
free and then he would say, "Okay, now
there's some other stuff we got to get
rid of."
I remember my wife one day I was at at
the house working and my wife and
children had went out to get I think it
was a Friday they went out to get
groceries and I remember
that day I felt something beginning to
manifest inside of me. Like literally, I
knew there's a demon inside of me. And I
was terrified because
normally it would be like a thought and
you kind of go, "I'm not going to think
that thought." And you keep pushing it
back and finally the thought goes away.
This wasn't that way. It was like this
thing kept getting it was like it was
filling up my insides and moving me out.
It felt like I was being shoved in the
trunk of the car and this thing was
taking over. And I was scared and I was
I was crying out to God. I was like, "I
need help. I don't know what to do. And
my wife got home and I was like, I need
prayer. So, I remember my my son and my
daughter, I think they went out on the
porch uh to play. And my wife is there
and she's putting the groceries on the
counter and starts putting them away.
And I came over and I I touched her on
the arm. I said I said, "Sarah, honey,"
I said, "I need your prayers." And she
didn't look at me. So, she didn't
realize how urgent this was. And she
said, "Okay, I'll pray for you." And she
kept putting groceries away. And inside
I felt like a little I felt like a child
that was in the back and I'm being
strangled and I need help. And I was
like, "Help me." You know, I was like I
wanted to scream but I couldn't get the
words to come out.
>> And I reached over and I grabbed her arm
more firmly and I said, "Sarah," I said,
"I need your prayers right now."
>> And she turned and looked at me and she
saw in my eyes and she realized this is
serious. This is not just casual. And
when she did that, she put everything
down and she put her hand on my shoulder
and she, you know, closed her eyes and
she started praying to the Lord and
claiming promises for me. And the most
terrifying thing happened.
>> This thing began speaking through me. It
was not me anymore.
>> I was literally I felt like myself being
jerked all the way back and something
else had complete control over what I
was doing. Wow. It was not even my
voice. And and I heard when she started
praying, this thing started laughing
like out loud laughing, mocking her.
>> Oh wow.
>> And I was like
>> I mean that terrified me because I was
like oh God what do I do? I mean this is
bad.
>> And when it started laughing,
>> it wasn't talking to her. It was just
laughing. My wife opened her eyes up and
it was like, "I know the spirit of God
came upon her in that moment." And she
looked and she said, "Oh, no you don't."
And she took her hand and put it on my
forehead and she it was like the whole
prayer changed. It was not, "Dear Lord,
we need you to do." It's like there was
the spirit of God in her. She put her
hand on my forehead and she started
rebuking that spirit and all these Bible
promises started coming out of her mouth
that I know she didn't remember.
>> Wow. and she was claiming the blood of
Jesus over me. This thing kept laughing
and I was sitting here
>> in my mind. It felt like I'm in the back
seat screaming for help. And I was like,
>> and one thought came to my mind. At the
name of Jesus, every knee must bow. And
I was like, and and in my head I was
saying this. I was like, you know what?
If I can't do anything else, I can sure
throw my face on this floor because we
had a a brick floor in our kitchen. I
was like, I can I can slam my face on
this floor. And I said, we're all going
to bow. Whoever's here, we're bowing.
>> And I did. I threw myself face first on
the floor. I spread my hands out, put my
face as deep into the floor as I could.
And my wife, she just kept followed me
all the way down. And then my daughter
and my son came in. And my daughter, and
I don't remember how old they were. I
think my son was about nine or 10. M
>> um but my daughter, she came over and
put her hand on on my back and started
praying and I was down on the floor and
my little boy came over beside my wife
and he was still little but I remember
he reached out his hand at somewhere
here like in my chest or shoulders and
he started praying for me and then this
thought came through my head. What if
this demon jumps out of me into my son?
you know, because people get afraid of
that. And I pushed him back from me. I
said, "Conor," I said, "Get back." I
said, "I don't want this thing jumping
into you." And this look came over my
son's face. I'll never forget it. He
looked at me and he said, "Daddy, the
devil can't come into me. He's got no
rights." And he put his hand back on top
of my head and he started praying.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And it was like
>> I was like,
>> it's that simple. A child.
>> Yeah. a child. You know what happened
while they were praying? I didn't see
anything, but I felt the presence of an
angel of God come into that room. And
when I say a presence, it was like there
was so much power. I can't even put it
into words. There was so much power, but
it was not the same kind of ugly power.
This was like you could just feel it. It
was light and holiness. And
>> and all of a sudden, the Lord allowed me
to see something. And it may it may have
just been a visual, but I saw this hand
grab like it was grabbing something that
was inside me. And it flung it. And I
didn't see what it was, but it just it
flung like that. And all of a sudden, it
was like I was free. My mind came back
to me. Everything change. And then I
jumped up and I Keith, he knows I didn't
used to be very um what's the word I'm
looking for? Smiley, happy, jolly, that
kind of stuff. Um, I I jumped up. There
were tears coming down my eyes and I
just started I raised my hands and
started screaming at the top of my
voice, "Hallelujah."
>> Wow.
>> And God is still in the business of
doing miracles.
>> Amen.
>> Bad break.
>> All right. I can do this.
All right.
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
>> Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean?
>> Oh, thank you. You know, we're all made
with a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork.
>> Wow. Where'd you get it?
>> Lightwear. Wear your witness.
He gave his disciples and my wife knew
this promise.
>> Amen.
>> Power and authority over all devils and
to heal all manner of sickness and all
manner of disease.
>> Amen.
>> And then listen to what he said. Then
Jesus commanded them and said, "Go ye
into all the world and proclaim these
glad tidings to every creature, saying,
the kingdom of heaven is at hand. Heal
the sick, cleanse the lepers, raise the
dead. Freely you have received, freely
given return. Amen. Free.
>> Amen.
>> You don't charge people for helping
them.
>> That's right.
>> Yes. In a ministry, you've got to you've
got to keep the ministry going. But you
know what? You don't charge people if
they ask for for help.
>> Yeah.
>> To get free. And I've had a lot of
Christians that tell me this. They say,
"Well, that was for the 12 disciples.
That doesn't apply to us today. That
stuff is is gone." Look what happened in
Luke chapter 10. After the 12, it says,
"The Lord appointed 70 others also, and
sent them two and two before his face
into every city and place whether he
himself would come." And he said unto
them, "The harvest truly is great. Look
where we are today."
>> Yeah.
>> "But the laborers are few. Pray
therefore the Lord of the har harvest
that he would send forth laborers into
his harvest."
>> Wow. Right here where Little Light is in
Chattanooga, you can go down some of the
streets and you will see people walking
and you know they're possessed by
devils.
>> That's right.
>> Do you know we've got people in our
churches, every denomination that are
sitting in the pew every single week and
they're in bondage and they need
somebody to pray for them to set them
free.
>> You know, yeah. there there um is a is a
sweet lady that that really um
she she's been a great family friend of
ours and she shows up at the schools and
she would walk up and down in the halls
and pray that God's angels would just be
with the students in the daytime. And
it's like, you know, here's somebody
that is really taking the spiritual
warfare seriously and and showing up and
and through faith just being like, I
want to pray that God's angels bind out
all of this, you know, nonsense that
comes into our our kids' space. And, you
know, do we do that with our churches,
>> man? We need to
>> we need to we need to walk in and out of
all those little Sabbath school rooms. I
mean, think about it. those seeds are
being planted into those kids that many
of them are walking away.
>> We can't we can't view the church and
say the church is perfect or the church
is a safe place because the devil would
love nothing more than to get inside the
church and corrupt us from the inside
out.
>> Sure, you do those um what do they what
what do they call those like the safety
things where they're you know make you
take a bunch of tests and show about how
many predators are statistically in your
church. It's it's scary.
>> It's scary. Um, I want to encourage our
viewers.
If you see somebody on the street or in
your church or in your school,
it's not the best way to go to them and
say, "I think you have a demon." Because
if there is if there's an evil spirit,
whether it be inside of them or whether
it be just in their life,
>> if there's this evil spirit that is
influencing that person, that spirit
will cause them to hate you for coming
to them and saying that.
>> They they won't even understand why they
feel this ugliness towards you, but they
will. They'll resist. If the Lord if he
opens your eyes to see a person that's
in need, start praying for them at home
alone and open your Bible when you're
praying for them and start finding
promises. Say, Lord, show me the
promises to claim for this person. As
you do that, you can ask the Lord, Lord,
open their blind eyes, help them to see
their need for Jesus and to ask for
help. Because then when they come and
ask, you have full permission to help
set them free. Amen. Because the devil
will say, "They didn't want your help.
>> They didn't ask for your help."
>> Yeah.
>> You have no right to interfere. But God
can say, "I've got so and so and so and
so and so. I've got these five people
that are praying for that person every
single week. I have every right to
interfere."
>> It was funny because after Jesus gave
that same commission that he gave to the
12, he gave it to those 70. Listen to
what happened when they returned from
their their mission journey that they
were going on into all these different
cities. It says, 'The 70 returned again
with joy, saying, Lord or sovereign
king, even the devils are subject unto
us through thy name. And Jesus said unto
them, and I put this there because this
is implied. Why are you surprised that
the devils are subject unto you in my
name? I beheld Satan as lightning fall
from heaven. Jesus is like, I'm the one
that kicked him out of heaven. Why are
you surprised he has to obey me down
here? He says, "Behold, I give unto
you." And you put your name in there
because the scriptures are not just
written. They are spoken to each of us
individually. He says, "I give unto you,
John or Susan or Paul or or Scotty or
Keith or Eric. I give unto you power to
tread on serpents and on scorpions and
over all the power of the enemy."
There's a verse in scripture where Jesus
says something to us. Our Lord and
Savior tells each of us, "You shall know
the truth and the truth shall make you
free."
>> Amen.
>> Now, I know Hollywood movies that have
quoted that. It doesn't say the truth
shall set you free. It says it'll make
you free.
>> Um, and let me show you why he said
that. When Jesus was being interrogated
by Pilate, when they were trying to get
him crucified,
Pilate asked him, "Are you a king?" And
Jesus said, you know, as you've said, so
I am. And then he said, that's the
reason I came into this world is to bear
witness to the truth. And then Pilate,
the next question came out of his mouth
was, "What is truth?"
>> I mean, he was I think he was sincere.
>> Sure.
>> And I know Jesus wanted him to be saved.
That's why he was sending visions to his
wife. Don't have anything to do with
this just man. He's innocent.
>> But Pilate asked that question, "What is
truth?" And you know, it's funny because
I remember when Christ had when he was
still working to get me completely free
and I was reading my Bible again and I
thought about that Jesus said, "You'll
know the truth and the truth will make
you free." And I told the Lord that day.
I was there in in our house. I was in my
office and I'm I'm reading my Bible and
I read that and I was like and I looked
up to God and I said, "I know the truth,
but I'm not free." Because I thought in
my mind, the truth is simply correct
doctrine. That's what truth was to me.
>> And a lot of Christians, that's what
they think truth is. It's limited to
simply correct doctrine. Mhm.
>> And I I read that and I was like and I
told the Lord, I said, "I know the
truth. I know correct doctrine, but I'm
not free."
>> Um, even though the Lord had set me free
from the martial arts and I still had
demons and and sin and baggage and I
wanted it all gone. In John chapter 1,
we're told that Jesus is the word of
God. The word was made flesh. In John
chapter um 8:32 he said you'll know the
truth and the truth shall make you free.
In John chap 14 verse 6 he says I am the
way the truth and the life. No man comes
to the father except by me.
>> So people talk about there being other
paths to get to God. There's not another
way.
>> It's only through the name of Jesus.
Mhm.
>> But then I looked up the word truth
because I was I was asking God that, you
know, what is truth? And God said,
"Eric, you don't even know what the word
truth means."
>> And I told I argued with God out loud. I
said, "I do know what it means. It means
correct doctrine." And it was as clear
as day. God said, "Look the word up."
>> Yeah.
>> And so I went to John chapter 17 where
Jesus was praying and he said, "Father,
sanctify them through thy truth. Thy
word is truth." And I was like, "Okay,
your word is truth. I still don't get
it." And I looked the word truth up and
it means the unfailing verity of God's
word.
>> God's word cannot fail.
>> He can't lie. The Bible says that
multiple times, it's impossible
>> for him to lie. If he says, "Look at
that beautiful green sky." The moment
the words come out of his mouth, the sky
becomes green.
>> If he says, "Peace be still." The sky
will not be like, "No, I don't feel like
doing that today."
>> That's right. So if he says now you're
clean through the word which I've spoken
unto you, you are.
>> Yeah.
>> But it takes faith to grasp that.
>> And I'll give you an example. Let's
pretend for a minute that um that Keith
is a billionaire.
>> That'd be nice.
>> And he he finds out our little ministry,
Isaiah Ministries. We've been doing some
work in in Africa and Kenya and and we
we've got this project and we took out a
loan from the bank for $100,000 to to
finish this project, this mission
project, and I'm not able to pay it
back. And I'm paying some huge interest
on that. And Keith finds out, and I
didn't know it because he's a wealthy
guy, so I don't talk to him at church. I
don't, you know, he doesn't I don't feel
like I'm connected in his sphere. But he
goes to my church. He also banks at the
same bank I do. So, and he also plays
golf with the the bank president. So,
Keith goes into the bank president one
day and he says, "Hey, how are you
doing, John?" And John, "Hi." And and
Keith says, "Listen, there's a guy that
I know that goes to my church that also
banks here. He's got a little ministry
called Isaiah Ministries." And he's got
a loan with you guys. And the bank
president says, "Yeah, yeah, he he does.
He's never going to pay that off. I
don't know why he ever did this. I mean,
you know, I'm sending in my $50 payment
every every week on a $100,000 loan or
every month. And um Keith says, "You
know, the Lord's just impressed me. I'm
going to pay that loan completely off."
He writes a check, hands it to the bank
president, and the bank president says,
puts it in the drawer, says, "It's
done."
So, he calls my house that night and
says, "Eric, I just want to let you
know, um, you don't know me, but I do go
to your church. um don't worry about
making any more payments on that
$100,000 loan. I paid it off today. And
he hangs up. And I'm like, and my wife's
like, "Who is that?" I say, "Oh, that
was this guy that we go to church with."
And she goes, "Yeah, I know him." And
I'm like, "He just called me. Sweet guy.
He just told me that he paid our loan
off at the bank." Man, that guy's nice,
but I don't believe him. I mean, he's
delusional. There's no way somebody
would pay off a hundred $100,000 loan.
has the loan been paid off
>> 100%.
>> But I keep writing my $50 checks every
month because I don't believe the phone
call that I got from him.
>> God has written us a letter.
>> He tells us if the son therefore shall
make you free,
>> you are free indeed. And because people
don't believe it, we keep right on
living in bondage.
>> Yeah, it's true. And that can be to sin
and it can be to demons because the sin
is what gives the demons the right.
>> There's a verse in Romans 1:1 16 that I
love and this has become really really
important to me especially over this
last year. The Apostle Paul was writing
and he said, "I am not ashamed of the
glad tidings." The word gospel means
good news. Glad tidings. I'm not ashamed
of the good news of Christ. Not ashamed
means if I call my son and I say, "Hey,
I'll be there to pick you up at six
o'clock after the game this evening." My
son's not like wondering if I'm going to
show up. I told him I'd be there. He
knows I'm not going to put him to shame
and let him down. God's not going to put
you to shame if you believe in him.
>> He says, "The gospel of Christ is the
power of God unto salvation to everyone
that believes."
>> So, you have to have faith. Mhm.
>> You have to have faith in God's word and
faith comes by hearing and hearing by
the word of God.
>> So when you're reading those promises
and I'm if you're struggling with
rejection where you feel re rejected, if
you're struggling with lust, if you're
struggling with um bitterness, if you're
struggling with whatever the problem is,
find the promises in God's word and
start reading them out loud and put your
name into those promises. And as you
read those words out loud, God's spirit
goes into you and gives you the faith of
Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> Ephesians chapter 1 verse 13 makes this
even clearer. Speaking of Jesus, it
says, "In whom you also trusted
after that you heard the word of truth,
>> even the glad tidings of your
salvation."
And I'm I'm going to say something here
and I want our viewers I want you to
dig.
>> I don't want you to think I'm a fanatic
or I'm a heretic, but I want to tell you
something. Do you know the Bible says
over and over again we've all all every
human being No, it says every human
being has already been saved.
>> It says that Titus 3 verse uh verse 4-7
and 2 Timothy 1:9. M
>> it says God has already saved us. And
people say, "Well, that can't be true
because not everybody's going to be in
heaven." There's only one thing that's
stopping them from being in heaven.
That's active faith. That means
believing God's word and then walking in
what they believe.
>> If you believe you're forgiven, you
don't keep asking for forgiveness.
>> Yeah. It is a strange thing when the
entire like Hollywood machine is always
talking about like you know the uh the
the Atlantis or the um the glass for the
youth what do they call that fountain of
youth and stuff like this right it's
like you know they make all these
fantastical ideas like don't you wish
you could live forever and it's like
they're offering you like this wide
variety of like wouldn't this be cool if
you have this but it's like you you you
are getting offered That
>> that's right. God is literally telling
you, I have already paid your debt.
>> Yeah.
>> It was paid on the cross 2,000 years
ago. Faith is not simply a mental
ascent. Oh, yeah. I believe it in my
head. Faith is what you do. If you
believe the debt has been paid, you stop
writing the checks to the bank. If you
believe you've been forgiven, instead of
begging God the next day again to
forgive you, you start thanking him. But
you walk like a person that's forgiven.
You walk in victory. You walk in
holiness.
>> Yeah.
>> If Christ has cleansed you, you put off
that old stuff and you walk in the
freedom as a son and daughter of God.
This is just a consolidation of the
Hebrew and the Greek words for
salvation. And you can look them up
online. Don't look in a dictionary. Look
in a concordance or a Greek or Hebrew
lexicon. Um, salvation literally
includes rescue, freedom, deliverance,
healing, restoration, or to restore and
make whole again.
>> And I asked the Lord the first time I
looked up the word salvation, I said,
"God, there's, you know, seven different
definitions. There are five different
definitions." I said, "Which one is
correct?"
>> All of them.
>> Amen. And I heard God, he spoke to me
and he said, "Which one do you need
today? They all apply to you.
>> And you know, it's it's interesting
because
>> if that salvation has already been paid
for us,
>> that's why Jesus did the miracles he
did. He He set the captives free from
demons. He healed the blind. He raised
the dead. He cast out demons. He Healed
the lepers. He did all of it. Made the
deaf to hear. straightened a woman's
back because he knew, I'm paying for
this on Calvary.
>> She's mine.
>> Mhm.
>> And then there was other places he went
where it says he couldn't do those works
because the people didn't believe.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> It's almost like that that, you know,
old story or proverb where it's like,
you know, the guy's on the roof of his
house in a flood and and you know, it's
like God sent in some some helicopter
and some other things and and he's like,
"No, that's cool. That's cool. I'm
waiting for God to to save me. And then
he
>> God's like, I did. I sent you two boats
and a helicopter.
>> What's up with that? What's up with
that? You know, yeah. He's given us the
proof that this works, that he's done
it, that he's paid the price. We're at
this state in the history of the world.
Do we actually believe it? Yes or no?
>> Amen. And that just means walk. And I'm
going to show you some verses. I know
people people have told me that's too
easy. Yeah.
>> Deliverance, even casting out evil
spirits, it's got to be more complicated
than that. It's not.
>> It's simply believe.
>> Those two couples that told me, you
know, when they were helping to set me
free and they said, you know, we don't
have to do things the way we used to
where there's five days and you're
praying around the clock and demons are
manifesting. They both of them different
denominations they both told me when we
go to prayer we say Lord we claim this
promise in faith and we tell the spirits
you are not allowed to manifest in any
other way than the Lord Jesus Christ
Christ permits you in leaving
and they said it stopped when they
started doing it everything stopped all
the craziness all the manifestations
>> it has nothing to do with rituals and
>> and God is revealing that to us. And I'm
not saying that people are setting
people free using those or doing wrong,
but I'm saying he's showing us a more
perfect way.
>> We need to do it the way Jesus did it.
>> Amen.
>> Mark chapter 16. And this is the end of
the world. This is the great commission.
Matthew 28 gives it and Mark 16 gives
it. Jesus said unto them, unto you and
I, "Go ye into all the world and
proclaim these glad tidings to every
creature." What glad tidings? All power
in heaven and earth has been given to
him. That's what he said in Matthew
28:18.
>> Go tell the whole world all power has
been given to me. Not only as God, but
as the man Christ Jesus. Because when he
came to this earth and became a man, he
went back to heaven as a man,
>> fully human and fully divine. Mhm.
>> He said, "And these signs shall follow
those of you that believe
>> in my name. You shall cast out devils.
You shall speak with new languages." You
know, we travel around the world.
Sometimes when the Lord opens that door,
you might be on the airplane, there's a
guy that speaks Chinese or some language
you don't know, and all of a sudden
you're talking to him and he understands
you and you don't know if it was you
that spoke in his language or he that
understood you in your language. It's
irrelevant. He heard the gospel of
Jesus.
>> He says, "In my name, you shall cast out
devils and speak with new languages.
They shall take up serpents." And that
word in Greek means literally loose the
hold of serpents. And if you drink any
deadly thing, it shall not hurt you.
They shall lay hands on the sick and the
sick shall recover.
>> That's what I I'm like, Lord, we're
there. I want I want to have that kind
of connection with you.
>> So then after the Lord had spoken unto
them, he was received up into heaven and
he sat on the right hand of God.
>> And the disciples went forth and
proclaimed everywhere and the Lord
working with them, confirming the word
that they were preaching with signs
following. Amen.
>> 1 Thessalonians 2:13, I love this. He
says, "And for this cause also, thank we
God without ceasing, because when you
receive the word of God, which you have
heard of us, you received it not as the
word of a mere man, but as it is in
truth, unfailing varity." The word of
God, which effectually workketh also in
you that believe.
>> God's word has power. He created the
entire universe just by speaking it.
>> That same word speaks to us and says,
"Now you're clean through the word which
I've spoken unto you. Your sins are
blotted out as far as the east is from
the west. So far have I removed them
from you." He's speaking to us
individually.
Markap 11, Jesus answering said unto
them, "Have faith in God. For verily I
say unto you, Susan or John or or
whatever your name is, that whosoever
shall say unto this mountain, Be thou
removed, and be thou cast into the sea,
and shall not doubt in his heart, but
shall believe that those things which
God saith shall come to pass, he shall
have whatsoever God saith.
>> In the I read King James, I trust the
King James. It says he there and it's
not capitalized. But when you read the
context and you read the rest of
scripture, I can't just walk around and
say, "I'm gonna believe that I'm going
to get a Lamborghini today, right?
>> I'm going to get a check for a million
dollars today and it's going to happen."
>> Right?
>> He's saying you find where God has
promised something and you can stand on
that promise.
>> When my wife was praying for me to come
home and for the Lord to set me free,
she stood on God's word. She didn't just
pray, "Dear God, please do this for me."
>> Right? She claimed those promises and
God answered.
>> He did exceeding abundantly above all
she could have asked or thought. Mark
11, Jesus goes on and says, "Therefore I
say unto you, what things soever you
desire when you pray, believe that you
receive them, and you shall have them."
Mhm.
>> For he that cometh to God must believe
that God is and that he is a rewarder of
those that diligently seek him.
>> The house that belongs to God. Evicting
the squatters. You know what a squatter
is? It's somebody that moves onto your
property. Maybe you've got five acres
and you go out there and you find
there's some guy that's been living on,
you know, that little acre that you
never look at. He's been there for six
months and he's trashing the place and
there's beer bottles. That's what demons
are inside our lives.
The Bible says, "Know ye not that you're
you are and your body is the temple of
God and that the spirit of God dwells in
you."
God wants us to recognize that our
bodies, our minds, our hearts are his
temple. So if there's something in your
life, whether that be it possessed or
inside where it's taken completely over
you or if it's just in your life
influencing you with whispers and talk,
that thing has no right to be there as
long as you haven't given it rights,
>> right? It's kind of an alarming thought.
The um it's Ezekiel that saw the
writings on the wall, right? And they
were all the just the images and the
evil things and
>> and you know um that is really the the
the images of the mind. I mean think
about how many images that we are
exposed to that are just evil nonsense.
>> Yeah. and terrible terrible things and
you know it's like thing things in God's
house like I often feel this this
experience too and coming in and
speaking into God's house and we're
showing video clips that you know are
clearly satanic things that have never
ever seen the inside of God's house and
I I feel like rotten and guilty and and
and like Lord please help me not to ruin
your house and and it's like you know
you think about what people do on a
daily basis is I mean they're they're
they're showing those images in the
temple of God like you know we are much
better than a building you know what I
mean so it's like
>> um if if you feel that those things
don't have a place in God's house then
why would you have them in the place of
God
>> Amen is so true and you know it's neat
because even though science says once
those memories have gone in they can
never be erased that's not true with God
because God says if any man or woman be
in Christ Jesus, you are a new creation.
>> True.
>> That means God says, "I blot them out.
They're gone. I don't fix you up. You're
brand new. I'm not going to defragment
your hard drive. I'm putting a brand new
hard drive in there."
>> Right?
>> And that's cool,
>> right?
>> The Bible says in Romans 6:16, "Know ye
not that to whom you yield yourselves as
servants to obey, his servants you are
to whom you obey." That's how the enemy
gains rights. When God says, "Set no
wicked thing before your eyes," and I go
watch a movie about whatever. It could
be lust, it can be a horror movie, it
can be violence, it can be whatever, I'm
opening the door to the enemy to begin
influencing me. And if I keep opening
that door, sooner or later, the enemy
actually steps inside of of your body.
>> And you don't want that. Mhm.
>> Because it takes surrender for him to be
evicted.
>> One of my favorite promises in Hosea 13.
And if you have struggled in sin or in
bondage or if you're struggling with an
evil spirit,
start reading God's promises to set you
free. Listen to this one and put your
name in this as we're reading it. Oh
Israel, that's you and I. You have
destroyed yourself. But in me is thine
help.
>> I will be thy king, for where is any
other that may save thee in all of thy
cities? I will ransom you from the power
of the grave. I will redeem you from
death. Oh death, I will be thy plagues.
Oh grave, I will be thy destruction and
repentance shall be hid from mine eyes.
And in Hebrew, that literally means I
won't change my mind. Acts chapter 2 and
chapter 4 says, "It shall come to pass
that whosoever shall call on the name of
the Lord shall be saved." And remember,
we looked that word up, what saved or
salvation means. Acts 4 says, "Neither
is there salvation in any other, for
there is none other name under heaven
given among men whereby we must be
saved."
>> This is the Greek words, the two primary
Greek words for salvation. Sotia and
Sodzo. Um, you know, when you look these
up in a strong concordance, it's
beautiful to see what they include. To
rescue, to deliver, health, salvation,
to save, to heal, to make or restore
whole, it says, "Whosoever calls upon
the name of Jesus," even his name has a
meaning.
>> When you look up the word Jesus in
Greek, it'll take you back to the Hebrew
where the root came from. It's Yahushua.
And And I know there's different ways to
pronounce that. Yesua. Yeshua. That's
not what we're dealing with. But when
you look up what that word actually
means, his name in the Hebrew actually
is the word salvation. In many of the
the verses,
>> it means Yhovah saves or Jehovah saves.
Yahweh is become our salvation. I think
that's so cool that that was written
above Jesus's like um cross. Yeah. You
know what I mean? Like like to me that's
just like um like amazing. You couldn't
ask the devil to to write that. Right.
>> He was probably mad.
>> And the Pharisees got mad and they said,
"Take it down. Say that." He only said
he only claimed to be the king of the
Jews.
>> And it's like
>> Pilot said, "What I've written, I've
written."
>> So rad. Look up in your own Bible and
read verse Isa chapter Isaiah Isaiah
chapter 12 verse 1-6.
>> It actually says there that he has
become our salvation, our freedom, our
healing, our restoration.
>> Wow.
>> It says that
>> that's what the angel come came and and
told Mary Matthew 1:21. And she will
bring forth a son and you shall call his
name Jesus for he will save his people
from their sins.
>> Amen. So,
>> amen.
>> I mean, it's clear in scripture when you
>> Yeah.
>> when you see it, even if you don't know
or understand those other languages, the
message comes across.
>> Yeah.
>> It's cool, too, because what Keith just
read there, he will. He shall save it.
Doesn't say I might. I'm going to try
to. Yeah.
>> He says, I will.
>> Yeah.
>> But we have to believe.
>> And I I I have had times in my life,
even in the last 18 years, where I
opened the door to the enemy. I'm not
talking about I watched some rated movie
or what it could be as simple as
overeating.
>> Yeah.
>> I knew I heard God's voice say, "Eric,
you've had enough." And I was like,
"Ah." And I just squashed that. I pushed
it in the back of my head. And do you
know what? I struggled afterward,
battling a demon of appetite. And do you
know what's beautiful? The only way I
could find freedom was by going back to
the word of God and reading the promises
that he has promised to save me. M
>> and as I read them, faith came back and
the enemy was driven out by the spirit
of the living God.
>> Amen.
>> That's the that's the role that we have
in helping other people to to to be
free.
People that have got a demon that's
either influencing them or is actually
inside of them, they need somebody that
believes God's word to speak his word in
faith to them.
>> Amen.
>> And that means God loves you. that
little girl that you know I told you
that I was talking to on the phone, you
know, she she wrote on there, "Please
tell him not to stop reading those. They
hate it." I kept reading, you know, and
then I was like really fired up reading.
After about I don't remember if it was
40 45 minutes, she started talking
again.
>> And it was so simple just reading to her
the promises that God loves her and the
demon was forced out not by me
>> but by the spirit of the living God.
Revelation 12 10 and 11 says, "We
overcome him, Satan, by the blood of the
lamb and by the word of your testimony."
This word testimony doesn't mean simply
you telling people about the good things
that God has done for you. It literally
means to profess or speak out loud. So I
can believe in my heart, but I have to
speak it. Out of the heart are the
issues of life and out of the heart the
mouth speaketh. Jesus says
>> yeah the word testimony in Greek is um
some variation on the word marteria
which is a variation of well it's where
we get the word martyr.
>> Yeah.
>> So when you see that word in in Greek
it's it's often in that
>> that
>> amen
>> that context. You know what did a what
did a martyr do? gave his life,
>> sealed their life with with their their
testimony. Yeah.
>> And that foundation of what God had
>> and that blood was a seed
>> to grow faith.
>> And you know what's interesting? The
very next part of that verse says they
loved not their own lives even unto
death.
>> Do you know our own life? Galatians
chapter 2 talks about that. I am
crucified with Christ. Nevertheless, I
live yet not I. Yeah. But Christ liveth
in me and the life which I now live in
this flesh.
>> We live by the faith of the son of God
who loved us and gave himself for us.
>> Amen.
>> So the moment I tell the Lord I'm
willing to die rather than yield to this
sin. He takes your sin and he gives you
Jesus.
>> Yeah. Those who uh find their life right
will lose it.
>> And those that lose it for my sake will
find it.
Romans chapter 10, the Lord tells each
of us that if you will confess with your
mouth, it says the Lord Jesus in the
King James, it actually means that Jesus
is sovereign king.
>> If you'll speak that out loud, Jesus is
my sovereign king. I'm yielding. And as
you're doing that, you're saying, "Lord,
show me my sins. Show me what rights the
devil or this evil spirit is claiming to
my life." If you ask God to do that,
he'll show you. It may be in your quiet
time alone. It may be in the middle of
the night. He'll show you. And when he
shows you, you fall on your face. Put
your face against the floor and say,
"Lord, I yield. I yield my life to you."
If you will confess with your mouth that
Jesus is your Lord. And if you will
believe in thine heart that God hath
raised him from the dead, thou shalt be
saved. Do you know why he can say that?
Because in Romans chapter 6 it says,
"When Christ was raised, we were in him
being raised to walk in newness of
life."
>> Says, "For with the heart a man believes
unto righteousness, but with your mouth
confession is made unto salvation.
>> For the scripture saith, whosoever
believeth on him, on Jesus shall not be
put to shame."
>> Amen.
>> Hallelujah. It says in James that faith
without works is dead.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, it says in in chapter 1 um 22
it says, "But be doers of the word."
>> Amen.
>> And not hearers only. Otherwise, it says
we deceive ourselves.
>> Yeah.
>> For if anyone is a hearer of the word
and not a doer, he is like a man
observing his natural face in a mirror.
For he observes himself goes away and
immediately forgets what kind of man he
is. But he who looks into the perfect
law of liberty and continues in it and
is not a forgetful hearer but a doer of
the work. This one will be blessed in
what he does.
>> Amen.
>> So
>> to believe is an action.
>> Is an action. It's it's you're going to
move forward in in what you believe.
>> That's right.
>> It's like you can say, you know,
I believe in uh I believe that that God
can keep me from smoking. Well, throw
away your cigarettes
>> and and keep speaking it. God, you have
set me free from cigarettes
>> because he he can set you free from
smoking. But there is a action on your
part that goes along with that faith
that says I believe he can because he's
you know it's like it says in Jude, God
can keep you from falling. So, so toss
him away because he's got it all figured
out. You know, you don't need that as a
crutch anymore. You don't have to keep
them just in case.
>> Amen.
>> So, it is an active process. Yeah,
>> that process only has to be as long as
you want to make it,
>> right?
>> Because some people, and I'll use
cigarettes for example, some people
struggle for 30 years to give them up.
Other people struggle for one day.
>> Yep.
>> It all depends on whether or not you're
willing to surrender and believe.
>> So, if I believe that God has set me
free, I start speaking that. And when
the devil comes back and starts
whispering, usually the devil or the
evil spirits when they talk to us, they
talk in our voice so that we'll think
it's our own thoughts.
Rebuke him. Speak God's word. We
overcome him by the word of God. Use the
sword of the spirit. Use the shield of
faith. Speak what God's word says. I
cannot sin because I am born of God. 1
John 3:9. I'm not going to yield because
God will keep me from falling. God, you
are faithful. Thanks be to God which
giveth me the victory. You've got to
make it present tense and you got to say
it's mine.
Amen.
>> Amen. Heat. Heat.